bonsoir nous sommes le 5 mars nouvelle
édition du 7 8 l'aktu le journal de la
rédaction et aujourd'hui nous débutons
avec ses meilleurs ouvriers de france
récompensé au sénat s'était donc ce
mercredi matin trois cent vingt lauréats
nationaux du concours un des meilleurs
apprentis de france qui ont reçu leur
médaille de jeunes apprentis qui
viennent des quatre coins de la france
il représente près de 100 métiers des
cuisiniers à la ferronnerie en passant
par la marqueterie sur bois ou encore
les travaux paysagers le concours des
meilleurs apprentis de france est ouvert
aux jeunes en formation initiale de
moins de 21 ans ils étaient plus de 5000
à travers le territoire à y participer
cette année il y avait forcément des
yvelinois que l'on écoute au micro de
claire cambier et de patrick jacques de
dixmude
quand on voit tous les meilleurs
ouvriers de france tout fin tous les
cuisiniers avec le col bleu blanc rouge
qui viennent vous serrez la main qui est
de me parler et séraphin c'est déjà ça
c'est beau et puis c'est vrai qu'il me
suis rendu quand même assez magnifique
quoi juste ici
là aussi
c'est un pur bonheur c'est ça fait
énormément plaisir et on va fêter ça
avec ce qu'il faut et puis un site
on va continuer de travailler le bas le
bike ce qu'on vise elle en ce moment
l'actualité de ce 5 mars c'est également
la réaction des sages femmes aux
déclarations de marisol touraine il hier
la ministre de la santé a annoncé pour
elle un nouveau statut médical à
l'hôpital andré mignot de versailles
cette avancée est plutôt bienvenue même
si on se demande encore concrètement et
qu'elles seront le résultat de ces
différentes annonces olivier maniscalco
jonathan vilma un nouveau statut pour
les sages-femmes marisol touraine
ministre de la santé l'a annoncé hier
matin les sages femmes qui entrent dans
leur cinquième mois de grève ont été
entendus et les choses devraient bouger
un nouveau statut des compétences mieux
reconnus ou encore une rémunération
revalorisé sur le principe les nouvelles
semblent plutôt bonnes oui mais sur le
principe seulement pour les sages femmes
à qui on promet beaucoup depuis
longtemps sans jamais rien de concret
ensuite
alors forcément elle reste prudente face
aux annonces de mouvement cette année il
fait et dure depuis le mois d'octobre le
16 octobre précisément mais l'histoire
d'accéder à un statut spécifique pour
les sages-femmes date déjà une envie de
tuer une revendication qui date déjà
depuis 2001 donc voilà on demande à voir
déjà certaines réponses du ministère ne
satisfont pas la profession pas de
statut similaire aux médecins dentistes
ou pharmacien comme réclamée et une
revalorisation salariale au stade de
projet dont les négociations n'ouvriront
qu'au mois d'avril
autre point qui divise la création d'un
statut hors fonction publique pour les
sages-femmes
les syndicats craignent dans ce cas une
précarisation de la profession
c'est une crainte qu'ils ont maintenant
il ya des lois qui disent qu'il faut x
sage femme pour x nombre d'accouchements
pourquoi si on change de statut il y
aurait besoin de moins de sages femmes
on ne comprend pas d'ores et déjà les
sages femmes ont annoncé que la grève
était maintenu au plan national
le mouvement devrait même se durcir dans
les prochaines semaines la collecte des
restos collecte nationale se déroule à
la fin de la semaine ce rendez-vous a
permis à l'an dernier de collecter plus
de 6 tonnes et demie soit l'équivalent
de 6 millions de repas je reçois sur ce
plateau henry fall bonsoir à vous êtes
seul responsable de la communication des
restos dans le département des yvelines
est également 20 ce monsieur bonsoir à
vous vous êtes le président du club de
handball de ben vous faites partie des
bénévoles qui seront sur le terrain non
pas pour la collecte mais aussi pour une
opération de solidarité toujours à
destination des restos ça débutera le
vendredi ça se terminera le dimanche on
va en parler dans un instant tout
d'abord on va parler de ce rendez-vous
de cette collecte nationale et de son
organisation sur le département
comment concrètement vont se passer les
choses pour vous pour vos écrits c'est
une grosse grosse opération qui va durer
donc tous le vendredi le samedi pour des
magasins qui sont ouverts le dimanche le
dimanche matin ses 40 magasins dans les
yvelines et ses 800 demi-journée de
bénévoles puisqu'on travaille par demi
journée c'est assez fatigant il faut
prendre des marchandises les mettre dans
cartons les trier et les pactes et
ensuite les transporter et donc c'est
assez lourd mais on remercie tous les
bénévoles qui ont bien voulu participer
à cette organisation est juste un petit
point pour vous c'est 120 tonnes l'année
dernière qu'on a ramassé sur les
yvelines avait six tonnes c'est un hyper
tonnes sur la déportation 20 tonnes dans
le département des yvelines jeu se son
département dvg oui il faudra vous
accorder avec les chiffres nationale
sont pas les mêmes chiffres dans les
communiqués de la cdc un travail énorme
6 une tonne c'est un grand c'est un
grand magasin 6 tonnes c'est un travail
énorme en tout cas menées par les
différents bénévoles ils sont 66 mille à
travers le territoire vous nous avez dit
plus de 800 millions de mines journée
fait 500 bénévoles sont bénévoles
ce jury qui viennent spontanément vous
aider ou ce sont des gens qui
travaillent tout au long de l'année avec
les restos annoncé beaucoup avaya bien
sûr les bénévoles qui travaillent tout
au long de l'année dont moi par exemple
je vais être au carrefour à côté d'ici
là au carrefour de saint quentin
mais il y en a beaucoup c'est des
bénévoles occasionnels qui prennent leur
demi-journée ou qui viennent le samedi
ou dimanche pour nous aider on a à peu
près un carnet de 2000 bénévoles
occasionnels qui nous ont écrit qu'ils
nous ont dit on voudrait un jour aider
les restos du coeur et on en profite
pour leur proposer de nous aider pour la
collecte des produits collectés les gens
qui les produit c'est des produits non
périssables bien entendu parce que ça va
nous servir pour alimenter toute la
campagne d'été qui fait c'est mais joint
et puis après septembre octobre et donc
je sois pas périssable et un accent
particulier s'il vous plaît qui
pourraient être mis sur les bébés parce
que c'est la nourriture très cher quoi
un pot de lait 1er âge c'est entre 15 et
20 au donc c'est lourd quoi acheter
et donc si on pouvait au lieu d'acheter
deux paquets de pâtes acheter un pot 2
les bébés premier âge fut remercierai
l'ensemble des contributeurs et toute
cette marchandise vont servir à
alimenter non seulement la fin de cette
campagne mais aussi la campagne qui va
suivre
voilà la plupart sûr on a 20 24 centres
sur les 24 je crois qu'un à 22 qui sont
ouverts toute l'année il y en a deux qui
sont pas ouverts c'est tout et donc il
faut alimenter pour les mois de mai juin
juillet pour certains il ya un même trap
est ouvert même en août
et puis ensuite septembre octobre voilà
on compte bien sûr sur la population
pour venir donner dans ses différents
supermarchés a mobilisé et puis il ya
aussi cette opération qui va se dérouler
en parallèle durant le week-end qui est
menée par le club de handball
bien sûr la ville de bn vincent mathieu
comment ça va se dérouler ce rendez vous
qui va permettre encore d'aider un peu
plus les restos alors c'est un rendez
vous sportif et culturel qui commence le
vendredi soir on attend des gens qui
sont là pour consommer des boissons des
sandwiches etc participer des enfants
pour participer une grande kermesse le
samedi après midi un tournoi aussi
sportif le samedi matin un spectacle un
spectacle sur le thème du cinéma cette
année le samedi soir avec un repas chaud
aussi donc tous et toutes petites
activités
on peut donner un petit peu de sous pour
récolter pour les restos du coeur il ya
eu également une urne qui a disposé à
l'entrée où on peut on peut mettre la
somme qu'on veut je dois remercier le
club de beynes qui vraiment fait un
travail formidable vous savez c'est pas
facile d'organiser comme ça mais une
manifestation qui va du coup on ne sait
pas la première année que ça fait une
vingtaine d'années c'est un ex président
qui dont le coeur était touché par
coluche qui a voulu donner un petit peu
sa contribution à peu près au même
moment que la création des restos du
coeur alors ça a commencé par un petit
week-end un petit tournoi où des gens
étaient invités etc qui rapportait un
petit peu de sous et puis et ça grossit
au fur et à mesure des années on s'est
renouvelée dans l'organisation
renouvelée dans les dents les gens qui
organise aussi plusieurs fois et pour
voilà pour arriver à ce résultat je sais
pas si on peut parler résultats
notamment quels sont les résultats en
moyenne ont réussi à collecter combien
d'argent alors là on est on est plutôt
content sur ces cinq ou six dernières
années puisque on arrive à faire entre
5000 et 9000 euros ce qui couvre
pour moi le le besoin en repas de ben
donc en fait c'est ce que je m'étais dit
en organisant ce week-end c'est dire si
ben arrive à organiser quelque chose qui
couvre les repas de ben si chaque
village fait ça dans les yvelines ou
même en france ça serait ça serait
l'idéal
des bennes partout justement est-ce que
s il ya beaucoup de clubs de villes où
ce genre d'initiative organise il y a
beaucoup de villes oui oui en ce parfum
on a deux types d'événements soit
sportif comme ben soient culturels silc
aura le concert etc
conflans fait un très très joli concert
il ya rambouillet musique municipale
fait un concert à
saint-arnoult-en-yvelines donc mais en
tout je vous le dirai ça fait une
dizaine de manifestations pas plus
donc c'est quand même exceptionnel ce
que fait ce que fait ben les
félicitations des responsables et
partenaires
je vais pas défendre je vais pas
défendre tout seul les félicitations
puisque c'est c'est tout le handball
club qui ceux qui se mobilisent ça fait
à peu près entre 40 et 50 bénévoles on
va dire qu'ils organisent ce week-end
après il ya aussi les associations de
ben qui veulent bien nous aider et faire
un petit passage voilà leur contribution
comme il comme il le souhaite
là est la mairie de ben évidemment qui
nous aide sur ce week-end les différents
acteurs partenaires associés on a
également j'ai pas parlé du tout de la
journée du dimanche mais on a on essaie
de détendre la la manifestation à des
associations qui viennent un peu plus
loin dans le département voir un peu
plus loin dans l'île de france
on a par exemple des champions de vtt
trial qui vont venir là le dimanche on a
des danseurs hip hop je te supplie
quelle ville mais qui ont participé aux
six mois ce sera tout au long du week
end un septennat mars et puis cette ce
point spécifique que vous évoquez c'est
pour la journée du dimanche voilà merci
d'être venu nous présenter cette
initiative une toute dernière question
rapidement au début de semaine nous
évoquions avec vous ce vol dont il a été
la victime les restos c'était un vol
d'une petite voiture d'une tractopelle
plus précisément d'or
on est on nous voisins aux puces ou pour
qu'ils m'en aux clayes-sous-bois on a
notre notre entrepôt les voisins de
l'entrepôt avait un petit tractopelle
sur le parking et des gens sont venus
voler le tractopelle il avait rien pour
le transporter et donc ils ont volé à
d'abord de démoli un premier camion
voulant le fracture et ils n'ont pas
réussi et ensuite ils ont volé un
deuxième camion qu'on a retrouvée brûlée
pour transporter tractopelle est ce que
vous avez trouvé une solution est ce que
les hommes se sont manifestés on a lancé
un appel pour essayer d'avoir un don
d'un camion 200 mille kilomètres même si
lille est pas beau ce n'est pas grave
parce que ça coûte quand même quatre
cinq mille euros 5000 euros pour
l'instant pas de retour pas de retour et
cohen ça m'embêterait donc d'avoir
utilisé l'argent de ben non pas pour
acheter la nourriture pour les plus
difficiles avec vous achetez un camion
comme ça on espère que cette fois-ci
l'appel sera entendu ce soir si vous
voulez venir en aide au restaurant en
prêtant en tout cas ne serait ce que le
camion sur le la durée de la collecte du
week-end vous êtes parce qu'on est
obligé d'en lucknow loué à entremont
peut pas faire merci à tous les deux
d'être venu nous parler de ces
initiatives autour des restos du coeur
les renseignements pratiques qui se sont
bien sûr affichée et nous poursuivons
sans plus attendre cette édition du 7 8
l'actu avec et de la culture jusqu'au 8
mars à magny les hameaux journée
internationale des droits des femmes
célébrée à travers différentes
manifestations aux couleurs cette année
de l'amérique du sud revient de bissy à
magny les hameaux ce n'est pas une
journée mais une semaine durant laquelle
la femme les femmes du monde sont
célébrées à l'occasion de la journée
internationale des droits des femmes
samedi 8 mars la ville et les
associations partenaires organisent une
semaine d'animations cette année sur la
thématique de l'amérique du sud
au programme par exemple visite à
l'estaminet de deux expositions
consacrées aux femmes d'amérique latine
atelier cuisine ou tacos et autres
empanadas réveille les papilles ou
encore cours de gym en rythme sur des
musiques me cayenne
au travers de ces invitations au voyage
l'objectif est de créer des moments de
partage et d échange pour les femmes
on ne fait pas des ateliers pour faire
des ateliers faut que ça a un sens et le
sens et le lien entre elles avec les
autres pas seulement autres femmes
d'ailleurs ce que la semaine de la fin
ne la concerne pas que les femmes comme
on est invités etc
et c'est vrai que ça ça permet vraiment
de elles font connaissance de plus en
plus entre elles elles échangent au
niveau de leurs enfants par rapport à
leurs enfants par rapport à l'éducation
c'est le sens c'est ça c'est le lien
social qu'elle tisse entre elles et avec
le quartier avec la vie et puis c'est
aussi une façon de comment dire de faire
comprendre ensemble de ce noeud
comprendre nous mêmes aussi de quoi on
est capable
en fait parce que l'on veut c'est faire
des tas de choses on peut faire des tas
de choses on le sait tout le monde ne le
sait pas mais bon voilà c'est de prendre
confiance en nous le plus en plus je
crois qu'on y arrivera coup comme ça
gagner en confiance en soi se sentir à
l'aise avec son corps et oser être belle
ce sont là les maîtres mouiller donné au
cours de l'atelier de conseil en image
dispensés également cette semaine s'est
donné des astuces des conseils faciles à
réaliser au quotidien
et pour tout public voilà jeunes moins
jeunes parce qu'en fait le loup qui
concerne tout le monde
j'aime beaucoup cette ce lien qui se
tisse avec les dames ce côté aussi où on
laisse tous les soucis on parle un peu
chiffon parle beauté consomme amant
jeunes à la recherche d'emploi c'est ce
côté entre femmes superbes comment
dirais-je et se laisse un peu s confie
on rigole
l'atelier aux allures de réunion entre
amis apportent les clés pour apprendre
notamment à se maquiller associer les
couleurs qui met en valeur et s'habiller
en fonction de sa morphologie
parce que si vous vous gardez bien par
rapport à tout à l'heure de retrouver
les différents arrêts yeux ça peut aider
voilà reprendre confiance en soi
ensuite un divorce celui-ci recherche
d'emploi enfin des diverses choses en ce
sens on se sent soutenu aidé s'est fait
dans la joie et dans la bonne humeur et
avec beaucoup d'empathie
la journée du samedi 8 mars annonce elle
aussi sous le signe de la convivialité
de 10 heures à 16 heures place au
plaisir sportif entre autres cours
d'aéroboxe zumba rallye pédestre et dès
20h30 la soirée se clôture par le
concert salsa le yemaya la banda douze
musiciens venus des quatre coins du
monde
et puis un sport insolite à présent le
foot golf rencontre improbable entre le
football et le golf principe simple une
tenue de golfeurs vintage un ballon de
football forcément et pierre terrain de
golf et jean pierre papin sylvain
wiltord d'anciens joueurs professionnels
sont les ambassadeurs de cette nouvelle
discipline et qui va même jusqu en
octobre prochain se décliner sous forme
de compétition l'afutt gulf cup 2014
première étape aujourd'hui à
feucherolles anthony rech étaient
présents pour la rédaction il a
rencontré à notamment sylvain wiltord
mais comme j'avais déjà joué alors
automatiquement au j'ai pris j'ai pris
le truc brossé comme une tactique un peu
au foot
taper fort au début et beaucoup de
technique vers la fin ça paraît simple
sa part été simple à vue on a
l'impression que c'est très simple et
finalement les distances sont
relativement faussé par rapport aux
enfants un terrain de foot où c'est
beaucoup plus rapprochés la cia la
distance est dure à jauger et après on a
forcément le terrain là que tu reviens à
demain 18h en direct nous vous point
complet sur l'actualité locale
excellente soirée sur notre antenne